Say we now add a transparent green object to our scene. To avoid our original
rendering problem, the rule is that all opaque objects are drawn first. So the
blue object is rendered. If we now render the green object, and then, the red
object in that order. The green object will block the red one. We want the blue
object to be affected by both the green and red filters. But the red filter is
rendered too late and has no effect. Just to make life exciting, say we add yet
another filter, a yellow one behind the blue object. This filter is not visible
for the pixel shown. But whatever solution we choose must make sure this object
is taken into account properly. My question to you is, which is the best
solution? The one that will give us the result of red blend to blue. And then
green blended over that. Draw all the transparent objects, sorted by their alpha
values, largest to smallest. Using the painter's algorithm, with the z-buffer
off. Sorted in back to front order. Or based on intensity, with the brightest
objects drawn first.